[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the break room this is
our daily live show that keeps you
updated on all the nerdy fandom news you
need to know live from our very own
break room right here at new Rockstar's
headquarters and at undiscosed disclosed
location they won't let me out they
won't let me out I don't know where we
are I'm scared I asked Brandon I was
like when can I leave and he's like you
never get to like yeah you never get to
leave well coming up on the show today
and door is coming for you one way or
another oh God get away from that sweet
sweet Ness we got Secret Wars updates uh
also Riri Williams is so much more than
what you saw in Black Panther wakanda
forever I don't know why I put that
affectation on that uh and speaking of
so much more we've got lots more but
first let's introduce the column
that's in a script well Tommy wrote this
also if we're blaming Tommy I don't
think we have Secret Wars updates I
think we have secret Invasion updates
we'll find out I'll get in there
always judgmental always we let him out
of the producer Booth I don't know why I
don't know is it a little producer Booth
is that what you call it it's a cubicle
yeah next is Josh got the beautiful
Jessica Clements beautiful
no you don't get that done absolutely
not work on yourself prove yourself to
him uh and next to me we got the always
effervacious Tom Michaels oh thank you
it is
that is a big word uh and if you want to
send in a super chat today we always
appreciate it thank you to the Super
Chat we already received from Christian
unpronounceable wakanda forever was
beautiful it was beautiful what was it
beautiful was me crying so much it'll go
back real fast but if you just said in
those super chats we're gonna do some
Thanksgiving style words yes because
Thanksgiving is near so for every
hundred dollars we're raising super
chats we're gonna give thanks to some of
our favorite things can you give us an
example yeah yeah I would like to see
I'm gonna take this one off the table
because it's the easy way for everybody
no if it's is it Android it's Android I
would love to give thanks to Andor God
bless you Tony Gilroy thank you so much
for letting this show happen thank you
to whoever at lucasfilm didn't cancel
this show before it got done thank you
so much for the show if you're in there
in the chat and you're sick of us
talking about Android go ahead and hit
that like button make sure
as we get into our headlines
uh James who you may know as director of
Logan or Kate Leopold recently confirmed
via Twitter that a trailer for Indiana
Jones 5 will be released in the next 30
days this is cruel
like what a strange thing also a missed
opportunity to have like a fun puzzle
like AR stuff but I think that like I
think we need to play that game right
like what sometimes these trailers are
attached to like big sporting events or
a holiday or what like is it a
Thanksgiving I think it's Faces Day
Parade okay there's an Indiana Jones
school and they bring out the Rockets
what if they have to escape from this
like giant boulder
give me the raquettes dressed as Nazis
with their faces melted
during the parade they're gonna pop in
and a Boulder's Gonna Roll out
it's immersive this is what you want
yeah
to the Ronald McDonald balloon and be
like Kalima it's gonna pull his heart
out
no Ronald McDonald's
there's a human heart inside the
McDonald's all right but I will say it's
probably [ __ ] huge it's like oh it's
really unhealthy you guys
I'm sure I'm sure you all are sick of
hearing from people who went to d23 and
was like the Indiana Jones 5 trailer was
the best thing I ever saw but it was
really good if they just say you think
it's the same thing yeah if they show
that trailer it'll be awesome if there's
more to it it'll be even better can you
give me a reminder of what was Phoebe
Water Bridge in the trailer what was the
kind of so the trailer was this
interesting mix I I keep describing it
as like the Indiana Jones clip show
where it was like there's old Indiana
yes but it's clear that the film is
going to have some like flashbacks to
Adventures we never saw oh and it was
like this great trailer where there was
like a mix of set pieces and things and
it was like oh this is great like
instead of one Adventure we're gonna see
all these different Adventures he went
on uh and Salah was back uh if you know
while a bridge was there as you pointed
out she came back she came back wow so
wait okay they are de-aging Harrison
Ford for this movie but also some of it
is reused footage well I don't I'm sure
they'll have some reused footage and
some like de-aged footage of Adventures
we never saw right it's a modern day
stuff okay because there was some still
old man India that was my thing with the
Irishman was like if they can figure out
how maybe they just needed to get a body
double first because it was like
watching watching Robert De Niro as like
a 25 year old man beat the [ __ ] out of
someone in the 90 year old's body was
like okay like the age to like 45 and
it's like wait are you because like a
lot of these guys at least for the
Irishman I haven't seen them in so long
so I'm like wait is this what you look
like now actually one of the things I
liked about the Irish family you were
like what what are you old are you older
than you're supposed to be or younger
than you're supposed to be the best
example of that DH stuff not quite
working with the old body uh is in
Captain Marvel we have a young a Young
MC Fury right played by a modern time
Samuel Jackson when he bends down to pet
the flirkin at one point to get back up
he like and he farts hands on his feet
are you here
whereas a young man in his late 20s
would just jump up right right
[Laughter]
so yeah excited for Indiana Jones 5
trailer in the next 30 days start the
clock give us a date speaking of give us
a date this weekend a surprise
collaborative short film between Disney
and Studio Ghibli Ghibli Ghibli I say
Ghibli I think uh dropped on Disney plus
this was after the like a day before
they had a little tweet kind of teasing
that they were working together like
everyone was like oh What's it gonna be
it's gonna be a cool like X-Wing story
it was it was grogu and the dust bunnies
it's really it's very cute it's three
minutes it's completely hand drawn which
is nice yeah it's beautiful it's very
stylized it was great it's cute put it
on for the kids if uh you know Disney
and Studio Ghibli have had this great
relationship for many many years now
Disney uh releasing their films in the
United States doing a lot of the heavy
lifting for the sort of like American or
English dub
um do you think this is gonna open the
door for more Partnerships between the
two students they're probably you have
to get Studio Ghibli you got to get them
on board I think right it's like they're
going to be down to do something but see
everybody's like just wait we have a
reputation 16 years there is that's all
that's like the thing is like Studio
Ghibli has their own demographic and
their own just like they're already on
their own pedestal yeah and then they're
like lump themselves lump themselves in
with Disney but to like take on Disney
it's like okay well you guys bring a lot
we have like an excellent array of
movies that only get like 100 I was
going to say I'm surprised but then
again I'm not that they didn't include
this as part of Like a Star Wars Visions
thing yeah then again it is Studio
Ghibli you know what I mean like it's a
whole other cheer about it with fandom
out there I also think they're learning
more that it's Studio Ghibli than it is
yeah it clearly is but it's like the
Studio Ghibli directed it I wonder if
they're the ones who called lucasfilm be
like we want to make a grogu thing with
Dust Bunny so I'm like okay yeah sure
sure
it's a three if you're not familiar it's
a three minute short film so it's like
really uh really digestible there's no
dialogue of course
um
maybe this is really reductive to
animators but it really felt to me like
some animator at Studio Ghibli was like
grogu's the cutest thing ever and I want
to like spend the next three or four
weeks like hand drawing this it like
feels like it feels really personal it
feels it's like it feels like someone
yeah super simple feels like one person
almost was like I made this cool thing
and and Disney or Star Wars was like
it's funny that you said that there's no
dialogue watch we booted up and grogu
has like a two minute monologue when I
was in Poland all of a sudden it's
completely like Cannon breaking What If
I sacrifice
everything yeah yeah I ate a mother's
eggs
exactly I did it for fun yeah stop it I
didn't stop I'm 55 years old and I can't
get laid okay I'm gonna eat the eggs
I saw it I saw that [ __ ] with my own
eyes
now they're just dust bunnies than
creditors
sorry spoilers
yeah Easter eggs you missed I'm sorry
sorry all right speaking of dead
children in the Star Wars Universe he
had the Andor official Twitter page and
or episodes one and two will be released
on ABC Hulu and FX starting November
23rd and free porn but we left that out
it was performed apologies to freeform
uh they're coming full court press
please watch this show please oh and
this is our play to you it's
Thanksgiving maybe you're with some of
your family that doesn't have Disney
Plus or whatever it is throw on a little
bit of Andor it I do love that they're
doing the first two episodes and not the
first three episodes because they want
to give you a little bit of anger you're
like yeah watch that third episode so
they just assume that like oh people
don't have Disney plus yeah or maybe
they're like because I'm like I don't
have ABC
I mean actually is it a broadcast I
think you do technically
oh that's true yeah
the only thing they could possibly ruin
Andor for me would be commercial
interruptions
or yeah yeah you're watching it on your
dad's poorly calibrated TV with like
rabbit ears it's a slow burn but I'll be
even slower watching on your parents TV
who still have like the motion blur
turned on
it plus uh but just wait this is just
the way Tony Gill really wanted this
series yeah I mean at least it shows
that you know they're they want this
show to be seen by more people which I
appreciate I really like that yeah
um speaking of Andorra in the interview
with variety uh Creator and showrunner
Tony Gilroy was saying that lucasfilm
restricted scenes of heavy sex and
violence in Andor I will say a lot of
the violence has gotten through uh but
Gilroy said there were things we
couldn't do quote I mean we have
standards and practices we can't have
sex X there's a level of violence that
we can't have there's limits on what we
can do we can't do some things that we
would want to do but within that we're
cool but they can imply like child
arranged marriages
if they could have put could you imagine
if Disney didn't own this if they were
like this is going straight to DVD or
something like the violence insects that
will be in it I mean the first episode
just doesn't really spoil anything
you've ever watched so yet implies that
Bix sleeps with her partner to shut him
up yeah and like it was the first time I
saw us we see like someone getting out
of bed and like putting their clothes
back on I was like whoa whoa
give me a pull Ed now
first curse word like the first [ __ ]
maybe a bastard yeah exactly we watched
Andor there's an extended scene of Andor
going after that pipe in the bathroom
he's where he's laying a pipe they
dropped a [ __ ] that's it this is my last
appearance on the break room I will be
signing off we already have one uh
member of the break room on suspension
we've got some wakanda forever and
Thunderbolts headlines to get to but
first we want to shout out some folks
that are helping us bring this week of
the break room to you and that includes
ink box inkbox tattoos they last just
one to two weeks uh so you can express
yourself I was like wait do you have it
I thought he wasn't I'm finished with
the beginning I'm sorry this is uh these
are inkbox Tech twos they last for one
or two weeks so you can express yourself
with the right tattoo for the mood
you're in right now without worrying
about whether or not you'll want it
forever uh there are over 10 000 tattoos
designs to choose from including a wide
variety of styles and sizes what we're
most interested in here at the break
room is their custom platform to let you
create your own totally unique tattoos
very easily we made a few especially for
the break room uh we got a little one
here probably just see it says it's
morbid time uh can I get that we got a
Gucci to mooch does this work uh let's
see who's let's do it it's hard to say
it's not focus
okay I failed we got a we got a Mephisto
watch tattoo but anyways so what we're
going to do looks like Harry Potter
you can kind of see it so what we're
gonna do we have these temporary tattoos
we have Tommy who's currently facing
suspension and Zach who's not here
either but they both agreed that one
that they would wear one of the other
guy's designs so so Tommy decided to
Gucci to moochie Zach designed it it's
Morgan time if you were here for the the
mug competition you know that's it's a
touchy subject for both of them so what
we're going to do we're gonna do votes
this week uh and if you vote for Zach
Tommy will have to wear it's more of a
time if you go for Tommy Zach will have
to wear it's Gucci muchi that's a little
backwards I think
yeah but it's it's uh you know vote for
the person you want to get the tattoo
that's what we'll say okay great yeah uh
if you could throw a book Pole right now
and foreign
I have a little ghosty on my arm right
now for for Halloween that's fading and
I'm not going to get yelled at by anyone
in my family for over things yeah my a
Haku from Studio Ghibli was on my leg
and it's gone now but I scheduled an
appointment to get the exact same tattoo
next three days so today
and then declare a winner on Thursday
and that they'll put the they'll put it
on on Thursday the winner will get the
tattoo put on them Tommy said he'd even
put on his stomach
hey promises promises you gotta pay
extra for that this is Tommy Tommy
agreed to this so he could get
unsuspended okay folks we gotta bring
him back
um so we'll do these tattoos today are
these the whole three days in a row
we'll get the winner they'll get
tattooed Thursday Friday they'll really
show it off because it takes a little
time to set in because these are good
tattoos to get your own ink box tattoos
click the link in the video description
or head to inkbox.com and use code new
rockstars to get 25 off your entire ink
box order there's no minimum order
requirement but you can only use that
code once so stock up think ahead get a
good bulk order together the code will
only be good until the end of 2022. do
we know the shelf life on these can you
order a bunch and then just kind of like
slowly over time I only want a new
tattoo this week oh next month I want to
get anything they each come like sealed
up which is really nice like these got
delivered on a day it was raining here
and our undisclosed location and the
package was wet and I was like oh no the
tattoos I would never know if it was
raining I can't see the Sun but they
were sealed up you hear it on the
Windows yeah yeah they're sealed up
perfectly so I think they have a good
shelf great I love that time You Got
Time time is on your side uh okay plant
derived packaging do that next headline
according to Hollywood Reporter The
Hollywood Reporter what kind of forever
launched into a record 180 million
dollar domestically that's over the
weekend from the 11th to the 13th and
330 million globally making it the
largest November Opening Ever which one
congratulations uh it'd be uh Mockingjay
Mockingjay yeah
it was a Hunger Games one when I thought
when I hear that also because this has
been all everywhere I'm like oh yeah I
don't really see movies in November yeah
well this is traditionally like Awards
season it's all the heavier fare that
maybe you know it's not like a big crowd
pleaser and it's like Christmas people
are just in December people go to the
theaters with family and I don't think
they do that for like Thanksgiving or
November yeah now people eat on
Thanksgiving and then when they watch
football
you want to go see a movie with me on
Thanksgiving
that Thanksgiving is like or the day
after Thanksgiving is the number one day
for plumbers uh sorry
that's insane oh my God last Friday they
call Brown Friday oh my God
yeah drink
a drink don't just stick to the starches
this Thanksgiving
grapefruit in the morning it's great for
your digestive system uh Black Panther
will kind of forever producer Nate Moore
confirmed that oh this is a big spoiler
so if you've not uh if you have not seen
them oh yeah yeah put the sport thing on
the old overlay like five seconds yeah
uh this is your spoiler warning come
back in five minutes uh if you haven't
seen black panther what kind of forever
yeah okay this is a black panther hey
Dazzle spoiler let's not put the text
lower third up yeah you know what I'm
saying yeah there we go okay this is a
spoiler okay so if you've seen the film
you're familiar with the post credit
scene uh Neymar is basically saying that
scene the the effects of that scene the
fact that all right you've been wanting
to spoil this up t'challa has a son oh
God I cried so hard that little kid has
a son
uh I was crying so hard oh my gosh uh he
said that idea was always part gonna be
part of the sequel before even Chadwick
Bozeman passed uh more said quote that
was always the end of the movie pretty
much since Chad's passing I think the
first draft we got had it in there and
the notion of the character introduced
in that scene actually predated Chad's
passing to be quite honest we always
like that idea uh so that that's kind of
impressive I mean it makes a lot of
sense narratively especially where you
know uh the MCU has been going this is
all about kids so many people have had
kids Thor has uh now adopted daughter
Hulk has the car we always joke about
Young Avengers but even the original
cast of The Young Avengers we thought
they're old enough to be the Avengers
now so right they're really like trying
to plan ahead I think but uh yeah so
that was always part of the plan
um I think it was that's pretty I mean
it goes with sort of like all the
stories we'd hear that Ryan coogler
basically took the script that he had
written and just like made a lot of
changes and the themes were this the
same the villain was the same you know
I'm sure all the telecon stuff was
pretty similar
um and yeah it makes sense yeah they
talked about cougars talked about
especially in that podcast the official
black panther podcast which is only one
episode out the rest of it doesn't come
out until January uh but if you haven't
listen to that it's great and he talks
about like he always wanted the idea of
Namor uh from the very first film and
they were like we have to wait on that
one uh and then Aquaman came out he was
like son of a [ __ ]
hey I mean hey look Disney Disney spent
eight billion dollars buying foxes
but they also
he had finished the script before in
childhood passed Senator Chadwick and
this is before you even send it into
Marvel for notes so yeah it was probably
already in there and that's cool that's
cool to hear yeah and I'm sure we'll
hear a lot more details about that okay
into the spoilers we won't talk about it
anymore I don't think there's any more
spoilers no no we're good spoiler's done
okay next headline except for that thing
where reread Williams says she dies and
gets brought back to life by the Vista
that is the sport okay uh don't don't
say that on the end sitting down with
variety actor Dominique Thorne said that
we didn't get to meet the real Riri
Williams in Black Panther what kind of
forever she said quote the film does
such a good job of showcasing one sliver
one side of who who she is we get that
little taste of the colors that exists
within her we see her as a hustler we
see her as a little bit of a bully we
see her as fearful we see her in all
these different lights but primarily
she's in a world of confusion this is
her outside of her element in the very
opposite of her comfort zone so the Riri
that we see is a bit of a fight poor
fight damn Dominic Thorne literally said
I'm ready that's an actress
that I don't know what that is because I
was like damn that was a good answer she
really understands the character and I
think it's a good thing of being like
you know she's mostly in the background
of scenes or like a sidekick she doesn't
get like a solo scene for the most part
of them I thought about it and I was
like uh and correct me if I'm wrong but
I don't think she ever found her name
she's carving that heart out of like
sheet metal and then the the suit is the
suit ends up being a vibranium nanotech
it's like I don't want it
too big of a super rudimentary suit and
sure he's like no she's like I gotta get
this stuff
like we have a 3D printer
and we got this vibranium over here you
want to use don't use that sheet metal
yeah they open a closet there's 50
different versions
but I agree
I agree with the headline yeah yeah I
mean this isn't it it's not her origin
story it's just like a sliver and it's
perfect because she like you know for a
lot of people including myself she like
stole the show you know it was one of
the greatest parts so it'd be fun if
you're just like actually we don't
really need the show anymore that was
pretty much what it is guys I mean yeah
it's great that we got a little bit of a
taste of it and and with such little to
do other than the action scenes it was
great yeah yeah I mean we got like half
a build hi and we got like half a build
Montage I wanted like full like you know
sweat on the
browser you know when that that laptop
she's back in her garage in Chicago
that's that outfit I was like damn where
I get those they need to start Lincoln
everything has like laces on me yeah I
mean Ruth Carter she's making it all
custom right I don't think so it looks
like a monkey
and another interview uh digital spine
spoke with Martin Freeman uh of course
plays ever K Ross and he sees the
crossovers in the upcoming secret
invasions nothing to do with Secret Wars
it's a secret Invasion series uh it's
it's an interesting quote he basically
says that it's very murky it's a a quote
quite Labyrinthian in terms of
Storytelling and the amount of people
crossing over with each over each other
end quote said Freeman I think it to be
that we're going to see a lot of Scrolls
impersonating Heroes that we know yeah a
lot of cameos
I'm so scared right every time we're
like this next thing is gonna have so
many cameos it was like Multiverse of
Madness we're like Cameo Fest we were
like Cameo Fest and now we're like
secret invasion you gotta put in here
because you need to have like the the
motherload of cash in order for it to
matter shape-shifting [ __ ] you gotta
have everybody back well it's over okay
so two things it's over time so it's
like everything that we saw in phase
four like for instance Val probably a
scroll all these other people that we've
already seen that was a scroll I think I
think
and so that and then secondly I we talk
about secret Innovation so much but I
don't see as much press as it for
everything else does that make sense it
I feel like it's not getting as much
hype as it should well they put out one
trailer we don't even know what it's
coming out yeah right they haven't given
us a release I feel like I hear more
about arming Wars than I do so that was
because you were like is it coming out
is it even happening yeah
hey I mean he got it he got elevated he
he went from a series to a movie like
that's you know maybe an elevation show
me a script show me the description
people in it doesn't exist I think I
think it'll be good but yeah it is
interesting when Martin Freeman to say
about secret Invasion I assume he's
going to be in it most definitely then
they certainly set up his character I
think black panther will kind of forever
did a good job adding multiple new
layers to his character and about where
it could go I think maybe he could be a
good squirrel that we've met oh my God
this is going to be a spoiler a little
bit okay
um this is uh you want to put up the
spoiler thing really quick I'm so sorry
spoiler um what if they take it when
they take him back to wakanda he's a
scroll that infiltrates if he is working
with Val in the long game or something
he's now where the vibrator is I am they
brought him right into this oh yeah I'm
fine with that all right and finally
David Harbor uh the Red Guardian he
spoke with io9 about the quote
interesting plans for Elena in the
upcoming Thunderbolts he said well what
what one what we want to do before this
character it's very interesting and how
I factor into how we develop our
relationship is very interesting loves
that word and then when you see what
Jake and Eric Pearson is trying to do to
Fashion it's really clever so you have
to have this movie that's you know kind
of ragtag end quote okay uh he also
spoke about the movie as a whole saying
it'll be funny it'll be weird it'll be
action and then uh and then we're also
gonna drop a bomb
oh really is that literal
it's gonna be literal and then also I
think it's going to lean more comedy
than it's gonna yeah yeah so yeah do you
think this is gonna be like
because these the Thunderbolts and The
Suicide Squad in comics it was a lot of
comparison between the two right really
do you think movie wise it's going to be
very similar because when they announced
the lineup for the Thunderbolts I would
argue it's less bad guy heavier than we
thought it was gonna be right yeah yeah
it's almost no bad guys right Taskmaster
redeemed ghost redeemed Red Guardian
kind of a good guy
he was he was the one trapping the key
oh my God he was bad at first you know
like all of these are all these are
characters that maybe were villains but
are now fully redeemed in the eyes of
the adventures
right I think they're also choosing
people no no offense and maybe I'm wrong
I think they are choosing people from
the lower of the franchises that we saw
like not to be again okay I didn't like
black widows so I'll say that which is
fair I think they're those movies to
flesh out the villains and they have
redeemed a lot of them and to their
credit they didn't kill off a lot of
yeah Marvel doesn't kill off their
villains a lot which is nice and if they
do kill people it's usually women and
they all these women have come back so
I'm like hey what's going on yeah I'm
very excited for them but I do think it
is going to be more comical than it is
going to be like right it's gonna be
them trying to get along and it's gonna
be like funny and we have like three uh
Shield throwing guys we got Red Guardian
we got um well and including Bucky who
knows how to do it then uh we have uh
Johnny mayonnaise and we have um
Taskmaster you know maybe they could you
know I could imagine it uh getting a
little bit had me up in there with them
I mean you got super soldier serum folks
but like no no laser eyes no Gods no
yeah none of that it's just like ghost
is the only one with like a power power
right that's true they're all are they
all super and what is her power she
could like face she's confused shake
your face
[Applause]
well she's not anymore tuna we don't
know he was supposed to go into the
quantum realm to save her and then he
conducted no I thought we do know
doesn't she do that
wasn't the whole thing wasn't the whole
post credit scene like we got to go into
the quantum realm the same ghost and
then Janet and Hank and Dustin and it's
a whole no they were going back to
collect data wasn't it I don't collect
Quantum juice yeah
it was for Quantum juice but I remember
that for sure uh someone's yelling at me
in the comments
get up to the tattoo Paul it was very
close Tommy pulled ahead with 56 so
Tommy right now has one don't give Tommy
what he wants your best of three polls
okay so tomorrow it's either Tommy or
Zach so if Tommy wins tomorrow we know
the answer but teams that there might be
a straight-up Zach really doesn't want
this tattoo so let's make him get it uh
we also want to thank uh the sponsor
today aspiration when it comes to
climate action your money is power baby
with aspiration a new kind of change is
in your pocket oh clever simply by
moving your money transformation you're
giving your deposits a cleaner Greener
leaner steamier home uh aspiration is a
climate friendly alternative for your
money get an account and debit card
that's built to help your wallet and the
planet aspiration lets you plant a tree
by rounding up every single swipe of
your credit card aspirations been hard
at work helping people align their money
with their values funding the planet of
funding the planting of over 100 million
trees fund the planet
100 million trees that's 50 million
hammocks folks on their way to funding
the planting of one billion trees by
2030. can you imagine 1 billion trees
rising up against us
okay it's no wonder why Forbes nerd why
and the pink ER recommend aspiration for
the eco-conscious best of all there's no
there's no no overdraft fees and with
aspiration you just pay what you think
is fair even if that's zero because
money shouldn't stand in the way of you
doing the right thing make your dollars
make a difference open an aspiration
account at aspiration.com
help save the planet with your
aspiration debit card open your account
at aspiration.com tree today that's
aspiration.com tree terms and condition
apply aspiration is not a bank deposits
there FDIC insured up to two million
dollars per deposit two dollars
bro
it's time for mandatory fun
I know I know I was just having a good
time it actually didn't even play the
graphic there it is it's not time for
mandatory fight it's time for our
discussion oh she's trying to catch you
guys off guard and it works hey look
here's the thing here's the thing here's
the thing Spider-Man came out everyone
was crying we saw the set photos of like
Tom and Zendaya and Jacob they were like
this is our last Spider-Man movie uh
everyone was like no it's not shut the
[ __ ] up
um but there was no deal in place but
now they're the Sony and Tom Holland
reportedly have signed a deal on the hot
Mike podcast Jeff Schneider confirmed
some like internet rumors he's like I
call my people I've got it it's happened
if you don't know who Snyder is uh he's
the guy who like first broke the blade
director news he broke Vision Quest as a
series he broke uh the the Harrison Ford
Thunderbolt right he is he's on run wow
and now he's got this Tom signed a deal
thing uh in the back so we're taking it
as fact
um now part of the rumor was that it was
going to be sort of this like six
appearance deal three of them would be
like Standalone Trilogy movies three
would be appearances sort of how they've
structured these Spider-Man deals in the
past uh can you know what it is
um on the podcast he only could confirm
that he signed this three episode part
of it there's gonna be a new Trilogy he
was like if I had to guess yeah we'd
maybe get five or six total movies for
this deal there's also a rumor going
around that part of the appearances
would be an appearance in Daredevil born
again and couldn't confirm that either
that's still just a rumor right now but
it was sort of like you know does Sony
really want Tom Holland one of his
appearances to be in a in a Disney Plus
show what if Snyder's just like the
devil and he knows everything that's
happening he just says if it happens
because watch this oh my God
that's the thing every now and then it's
been like should we cover this on the
show I don't really know how reliable
this guy is he's batting a thousand
right now but then it would be like
deadline drops the article right
afterwards so expect some some news from
some more official sources I mean the
Daredevil born again it kind of makes
sense right with Spider-Man totally I
want to go back to the streets
I was like yeah
I I wouldn't mind it uh I would I would
hope they just hold out for like
Deadpool instead and because Daredevil
board against coming pretty get ahead of
it get ahead of them I'm gonna ask you
about that in a second but
but the let's just kind of talk about
like this this first let's talk about
the trilogy right now right at the end
of no way home it kind of set up a few
few ideas for some future Spider-Man
movies you know the world not knowing
who Peter Parker is a little bit of like
a little symbiote in Mexico symbiote no
um Peter creating his own suit and
seemingly sort of like saying a little
bit of maybe a goodbye to to MJ and Ned
being like you guys are going off to
your college I'm gonna go maybe not go
to college or whatever who knows
um so I guess my question is like
they've dropped in all these little
threads where where do you we think that
the uh Spider-Man franchise is headed
but I want to get even more specific
than that okay because because this
isn't Rogue Theory why not sort of
approach this as factually as possible
right
um
so
if you look at kind of how Sony Marvel
deals have broken out thus far it seems
like Marvel has sort of been
disinterested in rehashing things that
have already been done by the previous
Spider-Man movies right they uh they
haven't really rebooted any of the
villains obviously we got a lot of them
back in the way home but those were the
same characters in a Multiverse
situation they didn't like do another
Norman Osborne they didn't do another
you know Sandman yeah all that kind of
stuff right
um and then they've sort of like changed
a lot of the characters MJ has a
different backstory and a different name
right uh Aunt May is is like a pretty
different character
um shaken up a lot of this stuff that
they've done and we have the Symbiote
right so like
we're gonna go back to a black suit
Spidey I don't know
you know I'm gonna get into that God
damn it
okay stop stop stop me if we can talk
about this later I think that uh it is
interesting that they don't do they do
not want to touch any of the old
Spider-Man stuff which I also agree with
don't do it but it is like they're
always still a little close to the
animated uh the across the spider verse
and the Miles Morales one where I'm like
come on you're saying you're sending it
up come on just just do it just do it
but I do like the Symbiote idea yeah
digital just put out that video this
weekend of like Tom Holland being an
into the spider-verse which there's some
rumors that Tom Holland Spiderman might
and they did their own version of that
um the Symbiote are you talking about at
the end of Carnage no in the
post-credits scene for no way home
remember when Tom Hardy's at that bar in
Mexico yes he's in it
and right before that I was rewatching
that seeing the prep for this he says
like I might have to go to New York to
like talk to this guy and then obviously
he gets so they've been sucked out oh
yeah so it's there's no Eddie Brock
right in the MCU right now but there is
well there could be an Eddie Brock sure
sure there's not there's not Tom Hardy
Eddie Edwina Brock
black suit Spidey uh symbiote Spidey
wouldn't that be a little too close too
that's what I'm saying well what if
they're gonna do like um sorry to
interrupt you know the Maguire ones uh
that 70 show
yeah yeah but I think what they might do
maybe is like kind of in the comics
where when the black suit was introduced
it wasn't a bad thing at first so he was
enjoying it I'm like maybe we'll have a
movie of him just being you know and
maybe it'll just allude to him being bad
and then you could pick that up later
because maybe they could even introduce
that in like the secret Wars movie
that's coming out which is also really
cool because that's where I debuted in
the comics thank you for talking about
Secret Wars we did promise about that
yeah so there you go
I also wondering like you know there's
two other things is one they they have
uh if Soda gets their way I mean they're
gonna have this the MCU Tom Holland is
close to their Sony versus stuff and
they're already filming craving right
now and we knew when the deal fell apart
between Marvel and Sony that they had a
craven script in the bag ready to go or
at least maybe it was a script it was a
story that with Tom Holland that they
were prepared to do to divorce them from
the MCU so maybe they could maybe in
their perfect world somebody's trying to
get him to get craving in there somehow
here's the thing they had it perfect
they could have done it at the end of no
way home right he could have found a way
to send him off to a different Universe
at the end of that movie and they didn't
do it so there had to have been
conversations between Marvel and Sony
about the future of Tom Holland and the
MCU right I'm sure they put them right
in Line in the Sand right like right
we're not part of the Sony version yeah
so I got another question on that same
line right
I'm going to give you an ultimatum
you get the Sinister sticks in a
Spider-Man movie but
it has to be the Sinister Six that Sony
is setting up
do you take it same actors you got more
BS you got that um
do you that's my ultimately the thing is
I want you could also do the Sinister
Six with different villains
no that's what I'm saying I don't want
to see those ones I don't want to see
those ones I want to know I want a new
book real quick who are those six let
we're saying it's morbius we're saying
it's vulture scorpion I'm not giving you
scorpion that was a that was a weird
scene
so vulture uh Craven uh Craven morbius
venom venom TBD tbdtv Madame web
yeah oh an El Muerte or whatever maybe
that's what they're doing we take Venom
away from the Sinister because you get
you got what you get yeah
six with those characters or you don't
get Sinister Six in this in this Trilogy
wait no you say no you don't want it
you go I I will allow it only because
you know we saw what John Watts did with
the villains from other movies some well
loves
which ones uh like digging Electro and
like kind of cleaning it up a little bit
uh
anyways John Watts confirmed for us no
no no no what I'm saying is like I I
don't 100 trust Sony all the time yes I
trust like Marvel guiding them and even
if they have were forced to use like
Jared Leto's morbius I think a good
director could get something good out of
that possibly do I want that no but if
that's all I get I'll take it and I
think to your point those characters do
a stint in the MCU they probably return
to the Sony Universe a little bit better
right a little we like that yeah yeah
Andrew Garfield Spider-Man movies were
pretty universally disliked right we'd
like to Andrew you are feeling that role
but those movies
now people are like give us a third
Amazing Spider-Man movie
I'm afraid of gambling I'm afraid of
gambling that much I don't want to lose
how much you have to put down on this
yeah seven thousand dollars all I want
is an old Spiderman like that seeing
like old Toby on older Spider-Man like
every time these spider franchises get
going like they end and you're like I
just want to see like an older wiser
Spider-Man that's one of the best things
about into the spider versus Peter B
Parker yeah being like no I've lived
this life and my back hurts and I've
lost my wife and like stuff out there
but like these are the these are the
sacrifices we make and I would love to
see Tom Holland kind of agent yeah be
really nice you know have the story that
they've done on the the PlayStation game
right where like Spider-Man's training
Miles Morales in the comic books too
right like that's what I see for the
future for Tom and like that's what I
really would like do you think I think
they just are like too afraid to like
make him old well they see Peter Parker
as like I mean a high schooler going
yeah the comics have stretched him out
as long as they can as a young man and
like slowly get him into colleges slowly
get a marriage like but then by the time
miles came around he was like the head
of the Parker Industries he was like a
Tony Stark type and then he could take
on a you know someone I'm sorry to like
hijack this for a second it is
interesting that it's like they always
want him to resonate with young people
and it's like yeah but we were young
that aged with him and so now we want to
see the older version of him I don't
know any other are there other like
characters that are like Spider-Man in
those ways where it's like yeah I
watched this he's been 16 for like 50
years and so it's like we do like
Smallville right you had a Superman who
became Superman right he starts out as
like a young Clark Kent small boy on the
farm yeah and then works his way up to
Metropolis and then at the very last
episode finally flies and you don't get
to see it and you don't get to see it oh
are you okay honey it's okay I think
it's fine it was a long 10 years
before Brandon has a complete break so
the other part of the that movie right
the other sort of loose end is the
Spider-Man identity stuff right uh no
one knows who Peter Parker is including
his friends including his family people
know that there's a Spider-Man but they
don't know who is Spiderman
a little messy little narrative ways to
interpret things
um
here's my question right
he he doesn't have a stark Tech suit
it's a lot easier for people to
impersonate
Spiderman now do you think we might see
some Spider-Man impersonators we have
the Symbiote we've never really gotten
Venom in The spumpsy doing the web
slinging stuff that he kind of does in
the comics and in other movies or maybe
a Kid From Brooklyn could be
impersonating Spider-Man well Miles
Morales you know that there's been all
these reports there's been all these
reports that like if they're going to be
done with Tom they're gonna want to tee
up miles right so and of course they do
right they've already introduced his
uncle right we've got Donald Glover uh
Prowler kind of maybe not really in the
MCU maybe they'll bring it back
um
everyone wants miles sooner rather than
later yeah right I know we see it we're
going to get to it
thank you
think of it I mean you talk about what's
left over to do I mean you point out
Prowler and Miles Morales also scorpion
that means something based absolutely
paid off uh it could be interesting to
see you know I I think I love the
Imposter idea because Spider-Man in the
comics his first big villain was
chameleon who impersonated him and
that's why most of New York hates
Spider-Man is because they think he's a
bad guy and they forget that like that
that's like kind of sets up his whole
storyline going forward is that he has
to go back and be like no no the first
year heard of Spider-Man was the guy
robbing banks that was an imposter I'm
the good guy uh I was thinking of those
it'll be interesting to see if now we
get a more proper J Jonah Jameson
reaction granted it's retreading a
little bit of this yes I think but it'll
be a new MCU version I agree with you
110 you not so much the only thing I
love that idea I love it so well they
can actually still do it I was gonna say
I really like that idea it's just it was
so close to the last Daredevil it's
exactly the exact same same thing in New
York yeah but I I love it and I want to
see it done again and I don't care if
they did it again I'm like do it again I
like that and you talk about no one
knows who he is and that's like a big
thing for Spider-Man and the comics
right like protecting his identity when
they go into Civil War that he takes the
side of like he doesn't want to shut it
he does show and he feels bad about it
uh and now he's kind of reset no one
knows and Daredevil pointed out uh in a
throwaway lined on She-Hulk that the
sokovia chords are gone so we have to
protect people of identity in that same
scene right he yeah he talks about
people's identity how important it is
maybe that is kind of our clue obviously
Tom Holland Spider-Man and Matt Murdock
have shared a scene before but the whole
reason for Spider-Man not revealing
himself is because he has to protect out
May he has to protect MJ they don't
exist for him anymore so it's like well
I think he's still I think he's still
you know he's still protecting MJ well
yes I mean I guess someone's hard to
trace MJ back to Peter Parker High
School together
[Music]
in the comics he makes a deal with
Mephisto so that he can see if it's
marriage what if this is already dead
but what if he makes a deal with the
pistols
magician though right which one oh uh
yeah they sort of did that plot line
right
a deal with a wizard is different with
the deal with the Devil
is always okay next question
too many questions again again
um trying to ask questions that maybe
have real answers right in the past
these deals have included this Clause we
don't talk about this a lot where Marvel
like kind of gives Sony a character from
the MCU right in the first movie you've
got Tony Stark being a mentor character
then in uh Spider-Man far from home you
have Nick Fury Maria Hill you've got
doctor strange and happy Hogan and uh in
no way home what is one character from
the MCU that you want to see personally
in at least one of these Trilogy movies
either acting as a mentor character or
just like a buddy the guy needs a friend
so these are friends not like Kingpin
like these are friends like already in
the MCU already established in the MCA
kingpin's not on the MCS not yet not yet
not yet okay
for JC JC's for Jason
I'm going to say Sony probably wants it
to be a character that is on the side of
good okay okay okay I'm gonna say too
I'm gonna say the one that I want and
the one that's realistic realistically
want to be like Maria Hill watch me
Maria what I really want Power broker
I loved in Black Panther them being like
oh [ __ ] you got Iron Man suit and then
like if he hears that he's like well
Iron Man was my like that was my boy and
then she's like I don't give up I don't
care I just made a suit
they've already put too many other
people in this movie give them Sam
Wilson Captain America right let him go
okay
he had his own movie and they put 16
other characters in it Brandon's right
here here you go
okay if not Kingpin
I was gonna say but okay then I'll say
maybe uh maybe I'm cheating a little bit
but let's bring in some of the other
Heroes out of his age like America
Chavez the new Hawkeye okay Bishop bring
some of them in maybe and have them have
some Adventures
this Trilogy of films is probably going
to come out after King Dynasty and
Secret Wars Maybe not maybe not uh I
want to see someone from I want to see a
little Reed Richards
already establishing
who cares
um
okay they've got the six picture deal
one of them is a trilogy two of them are
probably King Dynasty and Secret Wars
although I would argue you could
probably get one or the other you'd want
them in both but you could probably do
it it was mostly not an in-game yeah
right if you're not going to put him in
Born Again like the rumor States but so
maybe Sony is like no we're gonna do
movies only I'm taking Born Again off
I'm taking Fantastic Four off
uh what what movie it either announced
or we kind of suspect is coming do you
want uh Tom Holland I mean Deadpool was
a great one right yeah Apple's really
fun are we ignoring King Dynasty and
those bigger ones yeah I'm gonna say
those are pretty awesome so you get one
I want to say uh two oh yeah because
actually the he was there's some times
where he's trained Spidey on how to
fight the hand and stuff that'd be fun
yeah seeing them do some uh some food
colors
do you have one he already said Deadpool
Oh I thought you said Deadpool no he
said she kind of said it earlier he
looked at me because I'm pretty sure I
think he said beautiful okay well I
changed it okay I switched it up on him
I'm gonna say ironheart because I'm
obsessed with her and also well that's a
TV show too
um wait no TV shows I think if they I
think they just want move fees
she's probably gonna be an armor so you
can say armor Wars because that's a
movie now I'm not no no
the audio Adventures
they do this whole deal that they're
like sweating over for months and months
and months and he just gets punched by
Red Guardian for five seconds okay great
uh we do want to thank as John was
pointing out Batman the audio Adventures
uh the second season of the hit show is
on HBO Max now and it's it's an audio
show folks on HBO Max could you believe
it it's got an awesome cast that
includes Rosario Dawson John Leguizamo
and Bobby Moynihan Jeffrey Wright who
played Jim Gordon in the Batman of
course we all know he's now the cape
Crusader uh voicing Batman in the show
but not like that it's not like he not
in real life yeah yeah yeah well no I'm
saying yeah okay
Tommy's been listening to it he's
completely hooked on the series he will
not stop about that's part of the reason
why he's been suspended uh standouts for
him include harleen quinzel's what
character is that I don't I don't know I
think Tommy typo Harley quinzel's
Evolution into maybe the most insane
portrayal of Harley Quinn oh that makes
a lot of sense
[Laughter]
it's a great uh portrayal of her also
Seth Meyers is the voice of a radio DJ
he's kind of acts as like the audience's
surrogate in the show uh there's a
storyline with fun vignettes and
sketches full of Batman lore it's a
really fun show and it makes sense that
this show is funny because it was
created by a long time SNL writer Dennis
McNichols and he stacked the cast with
some common ringers like the people I
mentioned before and also Chris Parnell
Keenan Thompson tune in for a tale of
life and death in Gotham City the whole
season one is already available to
stream and season two is out now on HBO
Max again stream DC's Batman the audio
Adventures season two right now on HBO
Max yeah
introduction we'll get to some super
chats and then we'll say goodbye uh uh
you do good characters that's what I'm
saying I'm sorry I have to play a
character for this thing
where's the microphone so we're gonna do
some Thanksgiving we're gonna give
thanks as we approach Thanksgiving no no
one says you have to do a game we're
gonna give some thanks to our some of
our favorite fandoms thanks to our super
Chatters Bucky Barnes ATL he sees you
casa and he can't quit you the MJ 2997
why isn't Tom TB here so we can spam
Jets into the chat again tell me what's
suspended uh we're gonna work on getting
them back uh on the show he's got to pay
his Penance first uh the MJ also said
refund this super chat if sports are
banned when Tommy Bechtel is gone Jets
Jets Jets Jets I love the Jets fans
Tyler and Eve Harris sending a Super
Chat and or is so gritty and I love it
so much Tyler you are on the money my
guy and Haven saying giving thanks for
Brandon B oh thank you thank you so much
uh Lion of demise said my head Canon is
that no way home John Jonah Jameson is
it his first name is it John couldn't
tell you uh John Jenner Jameson wait uh
was the sixth Sinister Six which I love
he's got full Oath Keepers on Spiderman
I don't like it
uh bring me the Scorpion man back and
happy birthday to mess with JD is it
your birthday
happy birthday to you
happy birthday to
hi everybody oh wait he's got you can I
get the can I get the outro music
playing too if it's not already
the only one giving thanks oh you want
to all give thanks I'll give away let's
all give a little thanks I don't want it
okay uh hey this isn't for a fan and
this is for an individual Damon Lindelof
oh thank you thank you I know that
people hated you after lost and you know
some people could say rightfully so I
quite liked the Lost finale some people
hated you after that really bad Star
Trek movie some people hated you after
uh some people hated you after uh
Tomorrowland get to the thanks
Tomorrowland uh but then you did The
Leftovers oh and then you did watch me
oh watch me oh my God Watchman one of
the best shows
no no the Watchmen show
my favorite shows over the last you know
I don't know five or six years it was
great uh and it really really
transformed how I think of this genre
how I think of Storytelling and
television in general and I think how I
think about people wow I'm no longer a
racist
I don't know you put it in my ears
um who was yours too damn
do things David Hasselhoff because your
name is almost like Damon limeloff
what's his name
um I liked you in the SpongeBob movie
and
um
um you got it pay what you keep going
you also no he was he was the original
Nick Fury oh yeah never mind he was in
the Guardians of Galaxy Vol 2. he was
keep being a character for 80s people to
love
I want to say thank you to uh to the
crew here
they've been giving us all the great
things that we love every day but more
importantly because I just remembered
this I want to thank Ryan coogler for
even making black panther too he did not
have to do this movie guys after
Chadwick left us too soon this movie
could have easily been shelved it was
just too much too much to even take on
and yet he somehow squeezed out a movie
that was way better than it should have
been and gave us the entire he haven't
built the talocons A Whole New World of
characters that we have more to see and
it was just amazing if you haven't seen
black panther 2 go watch it thank you
Ryan Cooper thank you Ryan cooler uh I
already gave my things to Android you
know I love it it's great show God bless
uh but I got one more I got another
fandom thing can I change mine uh no you
love David Hasselhoff oh man who got
drunk once and ate Burgers on uh on uh
social media is that bad well he had a
bit of a drinking problem oh that's not
that doesn't make you bad
hey I want to say thank you to Mike
White and the white yeah let's go
Survivor Legend so weird so strange I
love the show the first scene was was
great second season is already popping
off it's not real folks there's no way
that thing was real it's got to be a
prostate
Leo James alone
but God bless the manifold and uh
apologies to any women or men he's run
into in a sexual nature in his life
because that must have been waiting on
the street uh but yeah thank you to
White Lotus what a great show loving
that show every everyone's only gonna
talk about that first episode oh my God
that first episode that was like a five
seconds oh my God I re-round I had to
show my roommate I was like we've been
talking about it at the office I need
you today yeah
hey thank you for tuning in to the break
room today we hope you join us uh right
here tomorrow at the same time live from
New rockstars uh headquarters be sure to
like And subscribe to the channel I like
the video If you haven't liked it
already subscribe to the channel if you
haven't already done that please do that
and be sure to check out Eric's uh Black
Panther wakanda forever breakdown which
is up now live on the channel uh
Jessica's got a great video about Black
Panther coming out uh on Thursday this
week uh check out all these videos on my
channel it's about Riri Williams in her
potential future in the MCU I hear she's
getting a TV show
for tuning in today we hope you had a
great day we have a great fun week here
as we always do on the break room so
great to see you Breakers all your
roomies out there in the chat uh latest
games and we'll see you next time tune
in tomorrow folks bye
[Music]
[Music]
thank you